that came into my head the idea that the
whole thing to be told from the heroes
point of view the camera would be John
Dominic Bobby the camera would do the
blinking and you'd only ever see him in
mirrors and reflections and of course in
flashbacks in due course I delivered the
screenplay Polanski made very
encouraging noises but added rather
ominously I thought now we lock
ourselves up until we're totally happy
for four weeks we worked every day from
dental six when a problem arose and I'd
make a suggestion that wasn't to his
liking he'd react as though I'd insulted
his wife you crazy that's terribly dry
let's have a coffee he said that is the
greatest script I have ever read I
turned to my wife and said he's not
going to do the movie I've been around
actress for 50 years I know the game and
I was right he went off and did three
pirate pictures what I call the
apostrophe s syndrome Steven Spielberg's
hamelech not Shakespeare's there's
something about that possession which
totally undermines what a film how a
film is made a film is a collaborative
effort and if I was 20 years younger I'd
ever go it fighting them but I'm still
night Michael
it is shot exquisite the first shot is
from a great great height and you see a
star what looks like a star in the
firmament and the camera goes in and in
and in and in and in and you slowly see
which is a prison camp sometimes I have
a vague idea where I want to be you have
to take into yourself what you think the
story is what is it about what is the
resolution that's required and I just
let that happen I don't think of it in
advance